do you have any members interested in
class
chair I'm a member of wingle with Parish
Council social we will withdraw for item
six
thank you
[Music]
uh we now move uh to our meeting held on
Tuesday the 25th of July
um with regard to the minutes of the
last meeting are we happy they are a
correct record is there a mover
second up
all those in favor
and abstentions
the motion is carried
all right thank you colleagues that
brings us to the main business of the
meeting our three applications before we
start I would like
to I would like the Clark to explain for
the benefit of member speakers and those
watching on YouTube how we will deal
with them
the procedure for considering the
business this afternoon
the chair will introduce an application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
these have been published on the
council's website and hard copies have
been circulated to you
after this the chair will ask any
speakers to address the meeting
there will be speakers on the first and
second applications
speakers will have three minutes to put
forward their views
they'll be reminder given by the clerk
when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the three minutes members
of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary to clarify any points they
have made
after the speaker has addressed the
committee and answered any questions
then they will be allowed to remain in
the meeting or they will not be allowed
to participate for participate further
from this point
the chair will then open up the meeting
for questions to officers a debate by
the committee and finally determination
on the application by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
family members this meeting is being
live streamed and recording will be
placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy this recording thank you chair
thank you
let's move on to the first application
Ned 22 stroke zero zero six eight six
stroke FL drum field
normal practices I'm going to ask the
planning officer as to tell us about any
late comment and to give a brief
presentation showing any photos and
plans of a site I will allow the
officers to complete their presentation
consequently members unless you have a
point of order that you feel cannot wait
could you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end
doing our first presentation today
thank you chair
the first item is full planning
application for the development of 27
New dwellings a sports Pavilion and
Associated access at land of Oak Hill
Road dronfield this is a major
development and we have um to amend the
title and her demanded drawings during
the application process and the late
representations were sent to you
yesterday I do have a slight update on
Boundary treatments which I'll cover in
my presentation if that's okay sure
the site outlined here in Orange is
located within the settlement
development limits for dronfield which
is a level one town and therefore
considered one of the most sustainable
settlements in the district the site is
not otherwise allocated in the local
plan for development
the site formerly housed the Gladys
Buxton adult education center which was
demolished in 2019. it is bounded by the
doctor's surgery near the entrance
dwellings on Oak Hill Road back onto the
site to the north and to the south and
east is a playing field you can also see
the rectangular paved area to the South
which serves as a parking for the
playing fields this is not located
within the application site is
considered that this area could
accommodate at least 75 cars
foreign
this is the red line plan for the
application site
part of the site shown here hatch brown
is included in the Brownfield register
and is therefore considered suitable for
redevelopment the remainder of the site
is is designated as sports facilities
shown here in green the surrounding
Sports pictures provide one adult and
one year's football pitch
this area is protected by local and
National policy which seeks to protect
and enhance all existing sports and
recreation facilities
sport England originally objected to the
loss of the designated area within the
red line and the changing rooms
after some research and discussion sport
England is accepted that the former
tennis court to the south of the
application site has been in use as a
car park for over 20 years and would be
sufficient to serve the remaining
playing fields
to mitigate the loss of the other areas
of the sports site and the changing
facilities the applicant has agreed to
include a two-team changing Pavilion in
the scheme the management of this
building will be secured as part of the
section 106 legal agreement
as a consequence sport England have
removed their objection
officers are therefore of the view that
the principle of development on this
site is acceptable
after negotiation with officers the
layout has been adjusted to meet many of
the criteria of good design outlined in
successful places
it features outward facing design
terminating views and sufficient parking
mostly located to the side or rear of
the properties a mixture of two three
and four bed houses are proposed of
designs based on standard house types
interest is created by a varied use of
materials and fenestration details
after having questions from Neighbors
about the boundary between the site and
the rear Gardens of Oak Hill Road I have
sought Clarity from the agent who
informed me yesterday that the
vegetation on this boundary will be cut
back under 1.8 meter high fence
installed offices are of the
understanding that the trees shown in
the drawing will be retained if members
are mining to approve the application
offices have recommended a condition to
provide further details on Boundary
treatments as well as a landscaping
scheme which includes tree protection
measures
the following slides show the house
types
so I'm just going to go through these
quite quickly that's the three a three
bed semi-detached
another three bed semi-detached
uh three bed semi-detached with a garage
two birds semi-detached
sorry too many pieces of paper and
a four bed detached
in it and is located at the center of
the site
and then most of the
um the plots also have garages either
single or double
um or
um groups of garages
okay
this photo is taken from the southeast
the application site is the raised area
to the right of the picture with
existing adjoining doctor surgery in the
background the sports Pavilion will be
located approximately where the trees in
the center of this photo stand
this photo is taken from within the site
the photo shows that the adjoining
properties on Oak Hill Road to the north
are located at a higher elevation than
the application site the levels of
elevation decreased from east to west
this is a view of the north east and
under the site from the playing fields
this is the center of disciples and
playing fields you can see the existing
boundary features with the dwellings on
Oak Hill Road
um and the view from the former tennis
courts parking area to site at the
proposed Pavilion overall an unbalance
officers consider that the proposal of
this design and layout in in a
sustainable location is acceptable and
are therefore recommending approvals
subject to conditions and the completion
of a full section 106 agreement the
legal agreement will include but is not
limited to provision of affordable
housing management of the sports
Pavilion and biodiversity Net game
provision
and that's everything thank you chair
thank you Alice uh right colleagues we
have three speakers on the application
the first two of whom is Elizabeth
Ransom an objector uh there will each
have three minutes to get over their
points and will be informed when they
have 30 seconds remain
as members you can ask to clarify any
matters that are being raised but
remember your questions should only
relate to the point which they have
already made
uh can we have the first speaker please
um yeah I don't no problem with that
so it's Paul Ransom
thank you
yeah that's no problem so you've got
you've got three minutes Paul if you
understood that
um thank you
um so we just wanted to raise a couple
of important questions really regarding
the proposed development of the Gladys
books and site firstly
um regarding the co-authority's comments
of the risk of gas emissions just
stating that the local planning
authorities should seek their own
technical advice on the gas hazards that
may exist and appropriate measures be
implemented from technically competent
personnel and can we have assurances
that this will be the case and that we
as interested parties will be able to
view any reports in a transparent and
open way such as email notification when
a report is submitted to planning
officials
um or the council and secondly can I ask
that the remediation and mitigation
measures regarding one stability are
also made available to interested
parties and so that we can ensure there
are no negative impacts to surrounding
houses
um
and then my final
um note would be to draw attention
really to the committee and the council
is that
um the current state of the playing
fields is not fit for purpose and they
need considerable work uh so the
provision of sports Pavilion
um would increase the use of this area
for sport and exercise which would be a
positive thing uh however as others have
commented I think in the comments uh
only if we have assurances that the
necessary work will be done to address
the state of the playing fields area
safe provision of parking as well as the
ongoing maintenance and monitoring of
this area as a Community Asset
thank you thank you
do any members have any questions
uh Council Cooper
good afternoon afternoon
um I'm just on the state of the actual
football fields how many is there just
to clarify uh there's actually three
pictures but I believe that was in in
the comments it was one adult and one
Junior but um I mean we both run
regularly in the area and we'd never run
on that field it's not it's not safe
it's uh there's the the state of the
fields now is just um it's an outfit for
it okay and how often is it used and are
the teams actually who are playing on
there I presume there are teams are they
part of leagues there aren't any teams
playing on there that I'm aware of no
not for and for many years and basically
I think the grass has just been caught
and it was it was wild and overgrown and
if you look at the goal posts they're
rusted and and have just been left for
years so I didn't believe there's been
any maintenance to that site for a long
time really in terms of football pitches
and who actually maintains a great who
actually maintains that that Sports area
uh well I assume it was established
you're going to council or drumfield
Town Council but I don't I'm not
actually aware of who's responsible for
it to be honest it used to be maintained
and for a number of years after the
school was demolished and the um the
education center was there they were
maintained to a decent level uh and you
did have teams training on them
okay thank you very much
nobody else
okay uh thank you you can see it again
I'll call Elizabeth Brampton
thank you whenever you're ready okay
thanks thank you hi everybody
um I'm pleased to see in the revised
plan that the trees hedgerows and
vegetation around the edge are remaining
as these have been there for many years
and would seriously impact the wildlife
and well-being of people who live on the
road if they were removed
um but I'm just worried about well what
sort of assurance and legal requirement
will take place to ensure that
building contractors don't damage trees
or remove vegetation I unders which will
disturb wildlife and nesting Birds
during the building work
and the plans describe and justify the
interaction to the existing houses in
section two four in the revised planning
statement as the site being
in quotation separated by a steep
embankment which leads up from the site
to the rear Gardens of the properties
along Oak Hill Road in most instances
the back Gardens are defined by a
significant level of trees and
vegetation which physically separates
the site from the rear Gardens of the
adjoining houses end of quotations but
it is correct in most instances the back
Gardens do have trees and vegetation
separating them from the proposed site
however not all the houses have a state
bank as you said earlier it does
it does taper off
on one side so it's not not much of a
steep Bank there is a bit of a bank but
it's not I won't describe it as as a
steep Bank there and
my interest is block 16 looks very close
to the end of our garden and next door
and
seems to have an open boundary
so
I'm concerned a couple of things that
concern me about plot 16 in particular
on the new design is it's going to
impinge on our privacy
and possibly light due to Elevation and
design of the planned house that's one
of the larger ones in relation to our
garden and house
um
so because the boundary is open I'm
concerned that the existing vegetation
won't really protected as stated in the
plan because if so that was my
comments really about it
okay thank you very much does uh anybody
have any questions
nope you can take back to your seat then
please
thank you thank you
[Music]
we now have um Tom broslin who is the
agent
if you'd like to take care take a seat
please
thank you whenever you're ready
thanks chair and good afternoon all I'm
some reason from abana sound planning
the agent for this application
I'd like to begin by reflecting on
what's been a very thorough and highly
collaborative application process the
scheme for you today is the products of
significant engagement with the
council's planning team and consulties
to get to this point of an officer
recommendation for approval is a
significant achievement and the credit
of both the applicant and your officers
who have been cooperative and robust
throughout
it's the firm belief of the applicant
that this scheme represents the best
outcome for the site and locality
bringing forward a development on
Brownfield and of a suitable density
providing much-needed new homes to
respond to acute local need
The Proposal is fully affordable housing
policy compliant with affordable units
to people the affordable units to be
provided as affordable rented as
requested by the local authorities
housing team
the applicant is also committed to meet
the full complement of section 106
requirements
the provision of a brand new sports
Pavilion with changing the shell
facilities for use by local sports teams
will anchor the development in the
community and provide a significant new
Community Asset that will enable the
continued development of local talent
and drive Sports participation
through cooperation with your offices
this scheme has also been significantly
reduced from an originally proposed 35
units to the 27 unit schemes you see
before you today
this process of iterative redesign has
resulted in a scheme which has achieved
the best possible layout with homes that
interacts with the open space and each
other according to the principles
outlined within the council's SPG on
successful places
from a highways perspective the
transport assessment has demonstrated to
the satisfaction of the highways officer
how the busy times have used for the
very few various different users of the
site that share the access will
fundamentally not clash with the
proposed
development
I was concentrated trips during the
working hours of the week and the sports
pitches and changing facilities
generating their most concentrated trips
on weekends
therefore highways the highways officer
is satisfied that the users combined
will not overwhelm The Junction without
Kill Road
the applicant is currently finalizing by
address net gain Arrangements while
whilst off-site on-site by the base net
gain isn't feasible despite extensive
Landscaping entry retention efforts an
off-site solution at thriftwood is being
explored upon Derbyshire County
council's Guidance the applicant is
committed to offsack
hard business
anybody given the context of a
nationwide housing crisis that is felt
particularly acutely in drum field
preventing money from accessing
sustainability settings left
circulating families in need of
affordable rent the positive
contribution of that this fully
affordable housing policy compliant
proposal will have in this regard cannot
be understated and therefore thank your
officers again for working with us to
ensure the quality and thoroughness of
the scheme and I strongly urge members
to support the recommendation for
approval thank you
uh thank you do any members have any uh
questions approach Clarity for the uh
agent
uh
councilor Cooper
um I have some concerns about the new
sports Pavilion
um from what I've heard earlier there's
no teams actually
based on that side because the pitches
are just not of a fit state to be able
to play football or other sports on by
the sound of it I mean they've even uh
just the the two early speaks have
described the fact that they don't even
run on there because it's not fit for
that
um do you propose to do any work to them
Sports does you talk about encouraging
sport which I fully endorse you talk
about talent I fully endorse all that
but without the actual facilities
and the teams
there's no there's no future there and
you've got a building that could it
effectively become a real problem to
that area uh it needs some ownership and
it and it needs some it needs some sort
of thinking about I think before you
just
before we put a sports Pavilion up
changing facility call it what you will
without the necessary
um
main thing in order I.E the playing
fields and the fact that people will use
it as it's meant to be used for and and
take some responsibility on for that
building and and what's more than we
need to be assured about the ownership
of that building
um so as as Alice mentioned the the
ownership will be secured as part of the
section 106.
um the applicant's currently in
discussions with Derbyshire County
Council who uh own uh the owner of the
the sports pitch adjacent to our size
that's not actually within our site
boundary
um but the ongoing discussions that will
be secured through the search model six
with between the agent and Derbyshire
County Council will but essentially work
all the work out who will be responsible
for the maintenance of the of this of
the sports Pavilion
um the pitches are within the site
boundary the the reason for the sports
William was a sport England objection
um in order to remove the sport England
objection they requested the provision
of the equivalent uh facilities that
were were lost when the score was
demolished in 2019
um so that's the reason for the
provision of the sports Pavilion and
maintenance will be will be discussed as
part of the search model six discussions
with Derbyshire County Council
thank you
um it's probably more appropriate
actually to ask Alice but I'll ask I'll
ask anyway because I've been told today
that Derbyshire County Council have
categorically said they do not want
ownership of that Sports Pavilion so
basically a sports Pavilion is being
built with no owners
nobody to run it thank you
any more questions
all right thank you you can um yeah I
think um the uh as I say that the reason
for the Pavilion being there was the
sport England objection
um the the discussions that the
applicant is having and we'll be sort of
confirmed with the tied into the section
106. uh it's not necessarily for
Derbyshire County Council to to take
over ownership is to find out who will
own it you know it's it's it's it's it's
not it's a discussion that's ongoing
um I'm not aware that there's been some
kind of complimental finalization as you
say at the moment
um but it it will have to be worked out
as part of the section 106 that this
application is is hinging upon
essentially
thank you
right
um all right colleagues we'll now move
on to the questions for officers uh
which I'm sure that will might be one of
them
um as always I would like to keep this
part of the proceeding focus on getting
clarity about any point you are not sure
of once we have done this we can then
have our discussion about the
application based on all that we have
heard and read
cancel it
thank you
um can I please have my comments uh
minuteed because it concerns me greatly
this because I can just see this
building becoming an anti-social
um hot spot shall we call it uh because
as it is at the moment they're putting a
building up and there's absolutely
nobody there's no team there's no
committees
there's not the County Council there's
nobody to run it so basically there's
just going to be a white elephant
building in a muddy field
so was there a question there
can I just change my mind on this okay
thank you
thank you Council again
um
the the if if members of minded to Grant
permission today it will be subject to
the section 106 agreement so
um if agreement can't be made about the
uh management of the sports Pavilion
then the permission
won't exist
um so in my view that is it we won't end
up with a white elephant because we have
to get that sorted out before the
decision can be but before the
development can go ahead
just if I can add to that chair that as
Alice says the recommendation before you
is to Grant permissions subject to that
106 agreement for which this would form
a part so if that wasn't achieved we
would need to find a way of addressing
that and that may and bringing that
about to yourselves because without the
Pavilion provision that additional
offsetting facility the comments and
concerns of support England may may
become relevant again so we would have
to find a way through that if we
couldn't achieve that through the 106
agreement
thank you for clarifying that any
further questions professors
Chancellor Cooper
thanks Jeff uh thanks for clarifying
that because that is a definite point to
a concern for myself as well
um
my next question is regarding the
comments made by Mrs Ranson regarding
the boundary treatment at 16.
um
can you just clarify what what the
situation is there please
[Music]
thank you councilor Cooper
um yeah plot 16 is slightly closer to
the boundary uh than we would normally
expect from
um
uh from the uh the guidance from uh
successful places however uh the way
that the uh the the house has been
designed
um the there are no overlooking with
first floor Windows
um that are within 10.5 meters of the
boundary
um and as I uh made I pointed out in um
in my in my presentation earlier
um there is actually going to be a a
fence along that boundary so any sort of
ground floor windows will not will be
blocked by that
um so we are of the view that although
it it's not 100 meeting uh successful
places that the the applicants of of
through the design have addressed the
concerns
um
is therefore acceptable
thank you
any more questions for officers Council
Cooper
um just a couple just going back to the
um
the changing facility I just want to
clarify because obviously not knowing
the site
is there access to the changing facility
from the existing car park and also is
there access onto the onto the actual
playing fields
from the changing facility without
actually going back onto the car park is
that attained led so what I wouldn't
want to see is people
children particularly running back down
over the car park potentially with with
cars maneuvering parking Etc
it'd be helpful if I showed you the
drawing again yep if you can bring that
up again please
zip back through
okay
um so the the changing Pavilion will be
there at the bottom oh
okay yeah that
um it's the long building at the bottom
of the site and the area that can be
used as car park is this whole area of
former tennis courts it's a really large
area I think it's something like 90
meters long by about 30 meters wide so
as you can see there is access to it
from The Pavilion and access across to
the playing field which are sort of to
the um to the east
is not without going across that piece
of land
but I can't see why it wouldn't be
possible to manage it in such a way that
you wouldn't have cars along that top
that top boundary at the minute this is
not laid out with only parking it's not
got like parking lines or anything
but I can't see why there wouldn't be a
possibility for that to happen and for
to be able to manage in a reasonable way
could that form part of the condition if
subject to the 106 going through could
that form part of the condition that we
make some access
no it's not within the red line of the
application right so I'm afraid it
couldn't I don't think the only um
suggestion I've got chairs if that were
um a particular concern to members that
potentially something that could be
included in the management of the
Pavilion and be included in a 106
agreement I think that would be the my
suggested Way Forward if that was a
concern to you
it is a concern because it's an health
and safety issue as far as I'm concerned
I wouldn't want people running back onto
that area
obviously there's a green area within
the boundary
is there no way that that could be used
as part of it
the there are two ways chair that um
it's planning committee are concerned
about that and would wish to Grant
permissions subject to that is to either
compose a condition requiring some some
walkway from The Pavilion that avoids
the car park or as I say included in the
management agreement and I'm sure one of
those would be appropriate and I I think
um would be covered by the
recommendation before you as officers we
would know at that point and address it
either by way of conditional through the
106 agreement to ensure that there is no
that there is access from the new
Pavilion building to the playing fields
that doesn't need to go through areas
where cars are parked I think that that
I think that encapsulates what you
consumers
consolidated
yeah
um Adrian I'm just
still a bit little confused if if
this is the management of this Pavilion
is part of the 106 agreement and there
is no management
how how do we move forward
apologize I don't know the exact same
people you've been talking to but we are
aware that there is
certainly advice towards not in writing
but in in verbal form a latent demand
for an area such as this for the use by
sports teams within dronfield and as Mr
Mr Breitling said to you that doesn't
necessarily mean that the County Council
need to take the building on it could be
a another but that would be something
that would be addressed through
completion of the 106 agreement so there
would be some ownership of the building
achieved through that and then that
would be ongoing thereafter
the issue that we've had as planners is
that there was a
against Mr Mr Bryce Lynn and Alice have
both mentioned there was a
objection from sport England which in
effect was something that had to be
addressed by the applicant and the local
planning Authority in conjunction to
move forwards and as officers we've
secured what is deemed to be an
appropriate mitigating provision because
the changing facilities used to be
within the adult education center and
they were lost when the building was
lost so in effect to
promote the ReUse of the playing area
and I know what's been said to you in by
speakers and by councilor Cooper that
the facilities as they are maybe need
some work on them but to secure the
long-term use of the playing facilities
a changing area was something that
I think it was the fa and the football
Foundation required and this is the
solution that's been found and is
planning Authority we believe that this
meets your policy objectives with regard
to the retention of a sports Area sports
pitches which is designated in your
local plan this is one of those and it's
the
outcome that we as planning officers
feel
happy with and we can recommend to you
approval of the scheme subject to the
provision of this as we keep on going
back to the
management and ownership of that
facility doesn't need to be the County
Council or necessarily a cows that could
be a private body or a football club for
example but that would be addressed
through the section 106 agreement
no more questions officers right thank
you for officers
um this is the final part of the process
our discussion about what we've heard
what we think and what we want to decide
but before we go any further I would
like the clerk to remind us about
motions
thank you chair
please bear in mind members that emotion
must be moved and seconded before a vote
is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
and that Amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer's recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reason for moving emotion against
officer recommendations should comprise
the relevant planning issues and be
supported by evidence as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations Falls
or in other words it is not past
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision
through a further motion
in favor of the recommend a to be
approved by the committee through
another vote thank you
thank you for that one
right I would like to open the floor for
debate
foreign
thank you chair
um I mean I've been on here a long time
and I think this is probably the only
application I've seen in years that
actually has the housing
supportive I think it's it's a little
bit worrying that sport England have put
this condition on that we've got to meet
in there but I agree with the word I
think Alice has done a sterling job
actually getting that sorted my only
concern with it is is the plot 16 issue
but again it seems as though everything
that can be done to mitigate it has been
done so I'm I'm part supportive of this
one
thank you
Council like it
I want to agree I mean I'm quite happy
about the proposal it's just that I do
think it's irresponsible to
put a building up with no management
already you know wanting it as it were
because I just I'm just very very
concerned that that Sports Pavilion
could end up as like I say AEM
anti-social Behavior
area uh
just just trying to to reassure members
on this point share that planning
permission
won't won't be granted if you are minded
to resolve this afternoon to Grant
permission it won't be granted
until unless a section 106 agreement
that secures the ongoing management of
the building has been secured and as I
said earlier chair if if the resolution
is based on that and that's not
addressed and secured we would need to
find a way of moving forward and that
may mean coming back to yourselves for a
reassessment of of the application and
all that that entails because there is
the sporting good issue so as best I can
chair I'm trying to reassure members
that thank you there won't be a building
constructed without that being secured
thank you for clarifying that area
and the other comments anybody else no
all right thank you colleagues uh I've
been heard everything today and the
officer recommendations before us uh
what is the view of the community on the
application I am now opening the floor
to motions
I'm happy to move that we accept office
and recommendations chair second nature
thank you second of our councilor rails
right I'll take a vote on that and I'm
sure we'll run the space
for the very accepting officer
recommendations yeah
that's too unanimous Joe
yep
sorry
um
if you would like to leave now and we
need to bring some more people in for
the next debate thank you
thank you for your participation thanks
uh it's just going to take a few minutes
while I bring the uh there's quite a few
speakers on the next item so
we need to bring those into the chamber
foreign
application
uh which is Ned 23 stroke zero zero six
one zero stroke FL cutthorpe
and contrast the planning officers to
tell us about any late comments and to
give a brief presentation showing any
photos and plans of the site I will
allow the officers
your feelings about the process until
the end
thank you uh pass you over to Alice
again who is going to do the second
presentation thanks
foreign
this application is for temporary
planning permission for sighting of a
mobile Farm shop and Cafe creation of
new access and parking at land to the
west side of cutthorpe Institute main
road
um the late reps were sent to you
yesterday but we have just at 5 plus 12
this afternoon received comments from
highways which in summary have no
objection subject to conditions with
regard to parking visibility supplies
and pedestrian visibility supplies
the application site is shown here in
Orange
the site is located outside of the
settlement development limits and is
therefore in the Northeast Derbyshire
Green Belt the site is also within the
primary area of multiple environmental
sensitivity or the aims
and this is therefore considered to be
in part of the district's most valued
landscapes
in the green belt inappropriate
development should not be approved
except in very special circumstances the
construction of new buildings is
regarded as inappropriate development
with some exceptions agricultural
buildings are considered an exception
however offices are of the view that as
the building will not be used for an
Agricultural purpose is located well
away from the other buildings
constituting the primary farm group and
The Works required to establish it are
considerable and permanent in character
and as such it cannot be classed as
either an agricultural building or a
temporary structure ancillary to the
farm operation
as a consequence The Proposal does not
meet any of the exceptions
the location plan is outlined here in
red
the block plan shows the building
located approximately 30 meters from The
Institute with a car parking area for 10
cars loads hard standing in between a
new access within the existing dry stone
wall will be created to Main Road
engineering works such as to form a car
park may be acceptable in the green belt
provided they preserve the openness of
the green belt and do not conflict with
its purposes
offices are of the view that such an
area of hard standing and wide access
point would both individually and
collectively fail to preserve the
spatial and visual openness and would
have an urbanizing impact on the green
belt
as a whole office is consider the
proposals to harm the green belt and
therefore it requires very special
circumstances for its approval
the building proposed is a modular
building which has the character of a
mobile home officers consider that it
fails to meet the high standard of
design required by the council's
countryside landscape and design
policies and will be harmful to the
valued landscape
the following photos are a selection
from yesterday's site visit
the site is currently an open arable
field there are no existing buildings
within the field
the site forms the setting of the
coronation tree seen here in the
foreground this is a locally important
Green Space as identified in the
emerging neighborhood plan you can see
that the site will be clearly visible
from the Green Space
to listability and can be seen in a
distance in these photos in this photo
when viewed from the settlement the
field as a whole provides an attractive
setting to the edge of the village and
when looking towards the Conservation
Area Office is consider it to have an
urbanizing impact on the views into the
Conservation Area
this is a view looking back towards from
from the West
officers consider that the proposal
would represent inappropriate
development which would by definition
harm the green belt it is also
considered that due to the design and
sighting of the building and parking
design and sighting the building and
parking would harm the character of the
valued landscape the applicants and
supporters have put forward what they
consider to be very special
circumstances including the need for a
local shop in the village however
offices are of the view that that they
hope they hold little weight as they are
in most instances unsubstantiated and in
any case do not outweigh the significant
harm identified
added to this it is considered that
design and sighting of the building and
Associated development is not informed
by or sympathetic to the distinctive
landscape character or primary area of
multiple environmental sensitivity it
would also impact dry Stonewall and a
green space and would therefore fail to
meet National local and emerging
neighborhood neighborhood plan policy
thank you chair
uh thank you Alice uh right colleagues
we are with 11 speakers now on this
application uh the first of whom is
Andrew Arrington an objector
um they will each have three minutes to
get over their points and they will be
informed when they have 30 seconds left
uh you can ask them to clarify matters
that have been raised but remember your
questions should relate to the points
which they have already made
by the uh teams I believe Andrew
Arrington
thank you
hello
yeah thank you thank you you've got
three minutes thank you thank you thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
speak to you today I like several others
I'm opposed to the application and I
hope you will support your planning
officer who is recommended refusal on
planning grounds Court thought is a
ribbon development on the edge of
Britain's first national park and the
proposed neighborhood plan of Brampton
Parish Council if adopted will and I
quote ensure any new development
requires no intrusion into the green
belt and respects distinctive character
individuality and setting an open
Countryside this development clearly
does not meet that test support for this
application is considerable if largely
unfocused some support is from
non-residents many of these responses
can be paraphrased as a good idea and
deserving to succeed but without
planning Merit supporters are making
much of a need for the cafe and farm
shop in the village perhaps we're
getting the lateral spread of cook
thought over a three-mile stretch of
road to many residents this shop and
Cafe will never be local also forgotten
is the fact that there was at one time a
corner shop a butcher shop and a post
office in the village all of which are
no more and can I mention here that what
I believe is the Caravan that will be
used as the shop stroke Cafe has been
delivered to the woods Farm it could be
that applicants have already taken your
approval for granted thank you for
listening to me today I hope you will
make your decision solely on the
planning aspects of the application and
nothing else thank you
uh thank you Mr
um have any members got any questions
about the points the speaker has raised
nope uh right we'll move straight on to
the second speaker uh which is Elizabeth
Wood the applicant
if you have three minutes
um if you press the microphone on like
that yeah thank you
dear chairman and committee I've lived
in cotsworth on our dairy farm for all
my life also I've got a few science and
nutrition degree it was one of the
applicants I'm deeply saddened to see
that the new jobs that are being
provided by the farm shop and cafe and
the same job that I'm currently doing
are seen as low skilled which I believe
is not the case
there are many skills needed to provide
the high level of food safety and
customer service which we are intending
to provide at the farm shop as well as
this we are wanting our staff to be able
to complete many jobs not just cooking
or waitressing we are hoping that they
will be able to pasteurize in the dairy
on the farm as well as make the ice
cream and other dairy products including
yogurt and cheese which we are hoping to
sell
I don't know about you but I wouldn't
want someone low skill producing the
food I'm going to eat the employment of
locals will mean that they can socialize
with the other people in the village
meaning that there is a homely feel
which we hope to portray
the local hope that we are wanting to
provide to the village is a much needed
necessity that the upcoming neighborhood
plan mentions a village shop is second
on The Village's list and the cafe is
fourth
this cements the fact that the village
wants it with even our objective saying
they would still use it
if this was placed at the farm it would
alienate a lot of the elderly residents
who are unable to drive or have mobility
issues meaning the Endeavor will not be
successful leading on from this the shop
will not provide us
um leading on from this the shop will
not only provide us with another place
to sell our farm produce but also
products from surrounding Farmers
meaning we can Source around eight
percent of our produce from locals
we already have a vending machine
selling our pasteurized milk on the farm
however we we have had people contact us
saying that it should be in a central
Village location that is easier to get
through get to as well as this we've had
complaints stating that it's dangerous
with the constant Farm traffic this
provides reasoning why the farm shop on
the farm will be unsuitable as it is
hard to get to and people would not want
to walk that distance with all the
shopping
all the shopping okay
the long Farm Lane that is needed to get
down is a single track that is also a
bridal way and footpath meaning that the
increased traffic volume will become a
danger to them I urge you the committee
to consider the point I have raised and
approve the application to create a
Village Farm Shopping Cafe for the
locals used together with the car park
for customers and The Institute users
thank you
thank you do any members have any
questions
about the points that have been raised
yes
um so with the building it's currently
open plan so um if
Farm shops more viable we'll we'll
extend it further into the room and if
the cafe is more viable we'll extend
that so it depends what's best for the
village
Council Cooper
it's already been sorted
okay
now for the questions you can retakes
thank you
the third speaker we have is also the
applicant Matthew Langley
all right then Matthew have three
minutes whenever you're ready thank you
dear chairman committee I'm Matthew one
of the applicants a member of the
chartered Institute of Management
accountants I'm here today to talk about
the unit itself and the temporary nature
of this we applied for a three-year
temporary permission with the view to
prove the viability to the community
without them committing to a permanent
Endeavor on the sides therefore we
believe that during the three years we
can prove that the land is more viable
to the community it's a farm shop and
Cafe than as the corner of the field
the proposed site currently takes up
half a percent of the total field volume
The Wildflower Meadow which we've given
up takes significantly More Than This
the whole building has been designed and
approved to British standards as a
caravan to allow it to be reinstated as
a field in a matter of hours if the farm
shop proves unsuccessful the unit itself
is comprised in two sections which yes
have already been delivered both on
wheeled steel chassis and they've got a
tow hitch at the front that can be towed
by four by fours which is the way they
ended up getting put where they are they
are joined together by
12 volts remain on Wheels and Axle samp
stands one-sided the units are cladded
externally with a composite dark wood
cladding and gray window surrounds all
in need to reduce the impact and ensure
it remains looking like a Farm building
the units are well insulated and
equipped with air heat pumps for Energy
Efficiency waste towards is collecting a
tank to be pumped away and a temporary
temporary Electric electrical collection
has already been quoted for by the
National Grid with the view of it being
disconnected and decommissioned at the
end of the three years the car park is a
crushed stone layer placed on a membrane
this will ensure that no impact to the
road parking is created and also aim to
improve Park in the local Village by
allowing the village Institute users who
currently do not have a car park so
where to park safely so they're not
blocking the bend this application was
strongly supported by the Institute
management committee for use of the car
park and has also been supported by the
parish council at the end of the three
years the car park will be removed in a
matter of hours not days with our
standard farm machinery the drystone
wall will be rebuilt by the Farms
drystone wallet and there'll be no
evidence of the shop ever being there
if should the project fail the shop can
be fully removed and the green belt
reinstated therefore there's no lasting
harm to the green belt we believe that
the temporary permission will allow us
to prove the viability and
sustainability and diversification of
the farm as Farmers we're always being
told back to diversify that's exactly
what we're trying to do with this
application
we're looking to diversify we set out to
engage with local residents by holding a
stall at the Village event and talking
to lots of groups to find out what was
required from the village
where they wanted and required by most
residents we're humbled by the support
we've received from the village and we
strongly hope you consider supporting
the farm and the village of this
application thank you
thank you any members have any questions
about the points that the nope right
we'll move on to the next speaker
which is the agent Dominic Cooney
I think I've only got three minutes
thank you thank you chairman
I'm Dominic Cooney a chartered Town
planner working for back Shores and I'm
speaking as the agent for the
application
we are disappointed to see the
recommendation for refusal the
applicants have proposed in this
application a farm shop with the lowest
impact possible using a mobile building
and a temporary permission that is
easily reversible
I'd like to draw the committee's
attention to the key aspects of this
application the reversibility of what is
proposed here the officer's report is
somewhat misleading in this respect but
the simple facts are as follows the
building meets the definition of a
caravan and can be installed or removed
in a day
the parking area will be crushed stone
laid on a geotextile membrane
so that it is entirely reversible
and dry stone walls are easy to
dismantle and rebuild at any time indeed
this goes on all the time on farms
across the land
the location for this building is not in
any area identified as a distinctive
view in the neighborhood plan
and I feel that the officer's report is
somewhat misleading it again in this
respect
it can be seen in the visualization
submitted that the building itself sits
very low in the landscape
the design of the building Timber
cladding with a corrugated roof is
typical of agricultural buildings Timber
sheds are very common on farms any other
material such as brick or concrete block
would be used for a permanent building
but this is not a permanent building
the main group of farm buildings is down
Green Lane and unmade road is also a
public Bridal way
and is well inside the cup Thorpe
Conservation Area
we consider this to be a much better
position than located right next to the
farm because of the issues down there
and the conflicts between Walkers and
horse riders that use Green Lane
the committee members will have noted on
the file the numerous letters of support
which far outweigh the small handful of
negative comments
as Matthew already pointed out the
parish council support the application
stating that it enjoys strong local
support particularly given that there
has not been a local shop for many years
which was highlighted in the Brampton
neighborhood plan and the opportunity to
purchase locally sourced produce from a
local Outlet is a sustainable benefit
and would have a positive impact on
reducing carbon emissions through
decreased food miles
so if planning system is also call a
local farm with such high levels of
support from residents and the parish
council's 30 seconds remain then
whatever happened to the localism ACT
we respectfully ask the committee to
approve this application today so that
Lizzie and Matthew and the rest of the
Wood family can secure the future of
their farming Enterprise in cutthorpe
thank you
uh thank you any members have any
questions about the points raised
councilor Falls
refer back to on the officers a moment
Dominic's touched on something where we
saw the um we saw the
visual earlier of the farm shop which is
sort of uh gray and blue and yellow yeah
Dominic has pointed out and it was in
some of the photos in the pack that this
can be clad with um with Timber
essentially
can we just double check that point that
that is because this this contravening
information there
the um
the cloud yes right okay
Dominic at the moment
then I just assure you that it's not
going to be yellow and blue and yeah
that's a technical drawing yeah and that
they were in in their drawings arrived
that it's arrived at that stage yes as I
understand it well no it's not even a
color that's just a technical drawing in
with the plans where the proper
elevation show in the timber cladding
but unfortunately they haven't been
shown in the presentation which I also
feel is a little bit misleading
thank you um so at the moment the dairy
farm dairy farms are struggling no
secret
is that viable or not viable without
this Edition
it is viable at the moment but obviously
the milk price fluctuates wildly as our
speakers have already pointed out
and
we've got the next generation of our
passionate speakers the next generation
of farmers and they want to ensure that
the farm continues to operate and as
they've already pointed out
diversification is the key and to be
able to sell their product directly to
the end user will the dairy products
being sold in there be exclusively from
their Farm definitely right thank you
uh thank you thanks
uh the next speaker web is uh David
Captain uh supporter
and you've got three minutes when you're
ready David thank you
Mr chairman of members of the planning
committee good afternoon I am as you've
said David catton I've lived in
Cutthroat for almost 25 years
on receiving the officers report a group
of cutthorp residents met to discuss its
contents we concluded that in July the
planning department quickly concluded
that the proposed location of the farm
shop was an incursion to the green belt
causing it harm in the terminology of
the national planning policy framework
so it must be rejected in the ensuing
two months the appointed case officer
trolled through the mppf the national
the local plan and the Brampton Parish
neighborhood plan and the opposing
comments to find examples of texts that
would justify a recommendation to reject
the application
we work from the opposite starting point
to find evidence that justifies approval
of the application we've had but a few
days since obtaining the officer's
report to unravel it
and the relevant documents yesterday we
submitted our case in a late
representation which I hope you have all
taken the opportunity to read and Digest
we are not skilled people with
professional experience in extracting
arguments from the rules and regulations
relevant to planning decisions
nevertheless we've done our best and my
colleagues will now attempt to show that
fair-minded judges should conclude that
this application may be approved
in recent years this
Council has approved six planning
applications relating to farm shops
located in the NAD Greenbelt these
involve new build premises extensions
tool or changes to the use of existing
buildings improvements to access as well
as provision of or extensions to parking
all for Farm shops
on the northeast Derbyshire District the
green belt
we have also found elsewhere in England
planning approvals for developments on
Greenbelt Land for purposes that seem
totally inappropriate
these were approved because the relevant
planning authorities deemed in each case
the benefits to their local Society
outweighed the harm to the green belt
expressed by our poses
members of the committee it is in your
power to disagree with the officer's
recommendations and approve this
application
all we ask is that you listen to my
colleagues as they attempt to
demonstrate that there are Provisions in
the nppf the local plan and the
neighborhood plan to justify your
approval of this application
thank you is there any members have any
questions
for the speaker
on the punchers no
all right okay if you'd like to retake
seat
at the next speaker is going to be
joining us by teams and it's Andrew
Hughes another supporter
uh is Andrew use their Martin
foreign
Andrew uses Andrew Hughes arrived
otherwise it might be best for sure to
just move to the next speaker and then
see if he arrives and due course
right we'll move on to the next speaker
um which is uh Jane Johnston
this is actually Tom yourself right
thank you
that's working today
so good afternoon everybody John Johnson
I'm a resident my wife and I are
resident in cat problem I've been for
about I think under 20 years as well and
I just wanted to pick up one of the key
issues really is around the game bit
this being on Greenbelt I'm just picking
up the comment in the officer's report
it says however it's not shown why the
proposed facility cannot be located a
women's settlement or why Greenbelt
location is essential to provide this
facility
in addition in granting a planning
consent the local planning Authority
could not guarantee that the site would
be used by other site owners for
purposes differing from these from those
set out by the applicant
officers conclude that the provision of
a shopping cart that would bring
Community benefits but there's no
overriding reason why a site within the
green bell is required to provide for it
I think your officer puts up a diagram
of cutlop and it is a long ribbon that
goes around the road and the settlement
area actually covers those buildings
that are in existence as they stand in
the moment outside of that is all the
green belt and the challenge that brings
is there is no area that is not already
populated with houses or whatever that
could be used for the the site which is
why that site's been chosen I think it
was either Andrew or Lizzy explained
very clearly that the existing facility
at the farm and the rest of it is down
quite a long road which is quite
difficult to get access to so the the
point they're chosen is the best sort of
location you could put a shop in in
cutgold and unfortunately it is on
Greenbelt but there is no area in the
settlement where you could put the shop
now that was the main point I think I
really wanted to get across the other
point around
um while the local the local planning
Authority can't guarantee that site
would not be used by other site owners
no actually I think the inference there
is you get scope you get other people
wanted to take on the green bill this is
on on the woods Farm you know they have
absolute control of this and there's no
attention I don't see any reason why so
the planning Authority wouldn't be able
to guarantee but there's no reason why
the Woods Family actually there's no
incentive for them to go outside of this
and use the land for other areas
and I think really that was all I wanted
to say
uh thank you do any members have any
questions on the points raised no thank
you we'll move on to the next speaker uh
which is Andrew Wood
there's also a supporter of the scheme
I think you only got three minutes when
you're ready
thank you Mr chairman good afternoon
everybody
um I'm actually the applicant's father
and the landowner uh I'm Dairy Farmer an
endangered species really uh over the
past two and a half years the number of
dairy farms in the UK has fallen from
ten thousand to seven and a half
thousand uh we're currently milk about
130 dairy cows producing a million
liters of milk a year which at the
moment is all taken to droitwich to be
processed and brought back to God knows
you know to the rest of the country to
wherever and it's all seemed crazy to us
that this milk is getting all that
distance to come away again we're
supposed to be going carbon neutral
aren't we we're supposed to be net zero
that's the thing and so when Elizabeth
came forward with the proposal of what
we were going to do
it made absolute sense to me that we
could protest the milk within a few
meters of where it comes out of the cow
and then we could literally sell it in
the village a few hundred meters up the
road the lane and
it just made absolute perfect sense you
know to do that we've got uh every year
we finish about 80 or 90 beef animals on
the on off the farm you know and again
they go to wherever you know why why
can't they be sold through the shop we
grow grass and cereals on the farm
there's no reason why we can't grow
other things we have land swap with the
neighborware he grows potatoes on some
of our land there's no reason why that
car you know all these things that can
be done locally that people go
everywhere to Source I mean again we've
heard of how diversification is the way
forward well how we're supposed to
diversify if we're not allowed to
diversify I mean we we understand the
green belt but you've got to remember
that the farm itself Falls within the
conservation area and is in close
proximity to list of buildings
um and because of Green Lane and the
farm it's a busy working farm we have
two full-time sorry three of us
full-time on the farm and then there's
two part-time employees there's always
something happening to have cars coming
down down to a shop or whatever all the
time to you know it's not safe Farm's
got a terrible health and safety record
we don't need something to make that
worse you know we want to make it better
and what better way than to do that in a
nice safe environment right next to the
road where people in the village can
come walk to and not use the cars you
know it just it just seemed to me a
no-brainer really
and when Elizabeth first came up with
the idea I said to them look if you want
to do it we're all for it we'll go to
the community and see what they want if
they don't want it forget it and they
went there and I've just been no
touched by the support of the local
community I I just cannot believe it the
numbers today about wishing as well and
how it goes on there's you know the
number of applications with hundreds of
them the people supporting it and I'll
just urge you to to think again if you'd
refuse it please talk to us let us help
let's do this for the community there's
got to be a way around this please
whatever we do I just ask that we try
and get something sorted because it is
the least bit of green belt if you like
the lowest where we're choosing Society
is the least impact on the Greenback
that's time check thank you
uh thank you and does any members have
any questions
about the points raised
nope we'll move on to the next speaker
which I believe is going to be Carl
Langley
thank you girl yeah three minutes thank
you thank you
so when uh I first learned that Matthew
and Lizzy wanted to open a farm shop to
sell local Farms Produce Michelle and I
decided to look around at other Farm
shops to try and understand what was
feasible and achievable
um a number of these when we came to
look at them were located in Greenbelt
and on the open Countryside which meant
you know for us you know it made sense
that that would possibly a possibility
one particular note uh is a farm shop at
stretton which is located away from the
main Farmstead development and there's a
similar size and appearance to what's
being proposed in this instance
look at the approval for that moment it
was interesting to notice that the
planning committee cited paragraphs 83
and 84 of the national planning policy
framework as this appears to be relevant
in this case also
but it seems to have been emitted from
the report provided by the planning
offices on this occasion
as the planning officers May recognize
there's no available location within the
current settlement development limits of
cut thought for the creation of a shop
for the community
within their report the planning officer
acknowledges the community benefits that
such a shop would bring and also
recognize as the link with Farm
diversification
whilst you may already be aware of the
contents of paragraphs 82 and 84 I would
just like to quote a specific a sentence
that will take them from the planning
report for stretton
the mppf also states that sites to meet
local business and Community needs in
rural areas may have to be found
adjacent to or Beyond existing
settlements and in locations that are
not well served by public transport
in these circumstances it is important
to ensure that development is sensitive
to its surroundings and does not have an
unacceptable impact on local roads
as this development is intended to both
both be sensitive to surrounding area
and will not impact the roads negatively
I would respect for that committee to
consider these points as well
uh thank you uh do any members have any
questions about the points raised
yeah counselor
hello to the stretton farm shop yes I
have that yeah so it's really not
interesting is it it's our new market no
cc is an open Countryside yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying because obviously
you've got the main road which is
stressing because they're five minutes
away
I wondered if you actually been there to
have a look yes of course I have yeah
yeah I enjoyed the cake as well just
before you asking
you're welcome
I hear no further questions I think you
can retake you see thank you
uh the next speaker will be Roger
Pendleton
which I believe is also a supporter of
the schemes
thank you got three minutes thank you
good afternoon German and member of the
council I'm talking mainly about the
quality of the view that has been raised
uh just to say the people of cuts off
living near The Institute enjoy fine
expansive views looking
to the South East over Chesterfield and
Beyond
uh from an elevation of 170 meters
because if you look at an OS map of the
area that precise point is 170 meters
above sea level
the cut-off Creamery proposal doesn't
threaten these views any more than a
growing sycamore tree would produce the
view which does reduce the view from
further up the road
the photo montage of the impact of the
proposed Cafe shows quite clearly that
it is barely visible lying behind the
stone wall and at a lower elevation on
the road and besides being on Wheels it
can be reorientated
a point on the stone walls are part of
our cherished landscape and we are
grateful that Andrew Wood scrupulously
maintains and reinstates these even
though it costs them around ten thousand
pounds per annum in turn it provides
employment to local stonewallers
in conclusion there is little to suggest
that the quality of view from kutzhop
are lessened by this proposal and we
should therefore approve it
that's all I've got to say thank you uh
any members have any questions about the
points waste oh thank you if you'd like
to rotate your seat and the final
speaker we have on this is uh John
Robinson
thank you you have three minutes when
you're ready thanks
Mr chairman I'm members of the committee
this is the application has a similarity
to a legal case there are Arguments for
and against you are the jury to decide
the matter of the strongest part
after the applicant's consultation with
our counselor Council Martin Packard he
decided and requested it go to the
committee
so the matter could be considered
thoroughly not just the officer's
decision
other counselors
you either the matters to consider
there's an economic development business
Health cleansing Community not just
whether some proposal is in the green
belt
these old these days all organizations
which include councils are encouraged to
be sustainable and diverse
this is exactly what this application is
about
one of the biggest problems this country
is facing at the moment is producing
more of what we need within the country
and also reducing the cost of what we
produce this is just a small step in the
in this direction and Andrew Wood has
already made that point about the
movement of milk
all the reasons why this application is
an exception within the definitions the
district's plan have been covered by the
previous speaker
if you turn down this application then I
am ensure that the parish council will
apply for a neighborhood development
order in conjunction with the
neighborhood plan which we believe will
soon be accepted as this order requires
a referendum judging by the present
support basis it would be soon be put
into practice
planning is also about schemes which
should benefit the community the
Brampton neighborhood plan does that as
explained by the previous speakers
over 65 members have supported this
proposal with only eight objections one
being an anonymous so doesn't count and
two from the same person one being me
which is an addition and one supports
the idea and would use it
but it fills it in the wrong place
this shows that the application has a
large number in support
be approved
to meet the communities not the unit one
letter is particularly relevant and I
quote I care for my elderly mother in
the village and will be a huge boost to
her mental health and well-being to have
somewhere local to shop and socialize I
call on you as counselors to decide on
what is the right decision to make
having heard all the positive reasons
for approving the application thank you
thank you any members have any questions
about the points raised
no thank you if you want to retake you
see
uh College you are now the opportunity
to put questions to the officer about
this officer about this application
do we have any questions for officers
councilor for awesome
and there's time Limited at three years
is it not and we have enforcement teams
that can make sure that if it was
approved that they would complying with
whatever motions we pass here today if
we decided to is that is that correct
a Time limited permission that's that's
correct
and you've heard this afternoon that if
the facility wasn't successful it would
be the intention to remove that that's
something you need to consider in in
your assessment chair but you've also
heard this afternoon that if the scheme
is successful it would be retained and
continued so I would
members to be guarded in terms of that
because if you were to Grant permission
for a Time limited three-year period you
would normally be doing that to assess
the impact of the development whether
after that you could
provide another permission that would
then continue that so I think this
afternoon you need to to strip the
application back to its basic elements
and
you need to determine the application in
accordance with the policies of your
development plan and
you've heard a lot that's happening
about other issues but the primary
consideration you have is the site lies
within the green belt where you have
very strong policies of restraint and
less very special circumstances outweigh
that and we've set out in the reporters
offices are assessment of that with that
needs to be where you you start from in
my advice to you if you feel that a
temporary permission for three years
outweighs any harm to the green belt
that you identify then of course you
could get permission for for three years
but I would advise members caution on
that chair because if the project was
successful I think you would be faced
with an application to then retain the
building in its current form on that
point
sort of two things come to mind about
key performance indicators there about
it doing what it says on the tin if it
was a three-year time limit application
at what point would it have to come back
here
to be reassessed for any
additional Works Etc
if you were minded worrying your mind
would have said about going through that
process if you're minded to Grant a
three-year temporary permission then you
would expect an application to come back
into the council for the removal of that
condition that would otherwise time
limit the permission
prior to that three years expiring
that would be a matter for the applicant
and if that wasn't the case in the three
years expire if you granted permission
for three years and that expired then
that will become a matter of the council
following it up as you say through the
the enforcement process
so as it stands if this were to be
passed
um hypothetically speaking within three
years everything would have to be
removed anyway
if there was no application to extend it
if that's the the way that you were you
would granted permission this afternoon
that's right yes okay thank you
any other questions
professors
nope
uh right then uh thank you for that
officers um this is the final part of
the process our discussion on what we've
heard what we think and what we want to
decide oh and I would like to open the
floor for debate
uh Christine can just put his mouth
well that's all that
I'm minded that we should really think
about this
I understand the points about the green
belt but then we've got you know
diversification for farmers and a great
public good
Council
food security is a serious concern in
this country at the moment and farming
in itself isn't a threat especially
Family Farms they're really struggling
and I think it's for people like
ourselves to try and make them as viable
as possible because
soon what we'll move to is a food system
where we get a lot of food miles it's
not locally sourced and produced when it
could have been if we'd have had a
can-do attitude to
Solutions such as this
the big issue here is encroachment on
the Green Belt but the green belt is
there to protect
land that would have otherwise be built
on
um unnecessarily
in this particular circumstance it's
quite clear that this is a temporary
building and has a lot of very is quite
a viable proposal that would have uh
positive impact locally as well as the
fact that it's going to help a family
keep farming in Northeast Derbyshire
which is extremely important
so
taking into account what we said about
the three years
I would like to invite any
um contributions from other members or
officers about what key performance
indications we could put in place
to the applicant that we can find a way
of them being able to achieve planning
today that would make sure it's viable
but also equitable
uh Adrian if you don't answer me
the advice we give us as planning
officers chair is is based on
the legal responsibilities that the
local planning Authority has to
determine applications in accordance
with a development plan unless material
matters contend otherwise or or outweigh
that position so in this instance
Channel I'll come back to the point that
Council force made in a second if I if I
may but the starting point for you has
to be whether or not the proposal lies
in accordance with the policies of your
discipline when when read as a whole and
I come back chair to the
primary issue in your officer's opinion
in this case is that the developers
proposed in the green belt where you
have strong policies of restraint and in
this instance the advice we're giving
you as officers is that the proposal
does not meet one of the exceptions to
developed in the green belt and so our
conclusion that it is
inappropriate development and that is by
definition harmful to the green belt in
our assessment chair we've then gone on
in the report to assess the level of
that time and we've concluded that there
is both Visual and spatial harm and
we're giving that significant weight in
in our assessment and then we go on to
discuss the the other material matters
that have been performed it's a very
special circumstances in our conclusion
is that they don't outweigh that
in terms of your assessment you need to
go through that same process
so I would urge members to go through
that same process now if you conclude
that it's inappropriate development then
you come on to the very special
circumstances that that counter the
force it and Council agar have been
talking about chat and then you must
consider whether they outweigh whatever
level of harm you contend there is to
the green belt and that's that's your
conclusion in terms of the point that
councilor force it made share the
assessment of whether the project is
successful or not would not be a matter
for yourselves that that is a matter for
the parties you need to consider the
matter in terms of
um issues that you've talked about
um diversification assisting the farm
um provision of a facility for local
people that that is what you need to to
weigh in the balance and you need to be
sure that in weighing all that any of
those other circumstances are not just
circumstances they are very special
circumstances and therefore we would
normally as officers and encourage you
to put that in the context of not easily
replicated elsewhere so you need to to
to balance all those things in the uh in
in the way that you you come to your
conclusion
if you were to conclude that they did
outweigh
the harm to the green belt if you
include this arm to the green bone then
you could put a three-year temporary
permission on that would normally be
there to allow the applicant to show
that their business has been successful
I would presume they would come back to
you in three years time with their
balance sheet saying it's been
successful it's it's
um achievable we've
um had this throughput and we've made
this amount of money and this is our
business plan going forwards and then
you could assess then if you wanted to
assess the issue of liability going
forwards into that assessment as whether
you wanted to then Grant a further
permission
extending the three years in effect
I was actually thinking about more about
the environmental impact and the
assessment of that because if milk is
being moved down a couple of where the
gentleman said but a long way away and
that transport then is you know the
carbon that's being created whereas if
if it were possible for us today if it's
not already included I don't recall it
where there was exclusive sale of dairy
products from the farm only within that
shop that is already reducing food
mileage and carbon impact thus there is
a greater environmental
outcome by having that shop there than
removing the land you know as it as it
presently is and it's
um impact on the environment being used
for the growth of crop crops
so that's the um that's the that's what
I'm looking at there is well if if that
if that dairy product is being sold
locally and it's not being transported
all that way that far outweighs growing
let's say a third of an acre's worth of
grain there uh every year
in circumstances elsewhere in the
district we have
Place conditions on approvals for Farm
shops requiring the level of produce
within those Farm shops to be
provided from X or within a radius of we
do find them difficult to enforce
because we've all visited Farm shops and
the range of products often exceeds as
before this afternoon milk related
products or beef related products or
serial related products that they often
um exceed that so from an enforceability
point of view we have found difficulty
in ensuring that but for example you
could condition that only produce
grown or developed on the farm could be
sold in the farm shop but it does have
those enforceability difficulties for us
and and I've had no concept I'm afraid I
apologize I have no concept of what one
million liters of milk looks like or who
it who it provides for um just no
concept of that so whether that could
all be kept within the farm shop and
avoid the trips to droitwich I Don't
Know But I've no concept of how that
that would work or how how 80 beef
cattle translate to to produce so but
you could
um if you were minded having gone
through all the other steps the planning
steps to to want to condition that to
achieve the reduction in the the carbon
footprint and that was one of your very
special reasons then you could place
those conditions on but I do have that
caveat that they are traditionally
difficult to enforce
thanks chair this is this is one of
those applications I hate because your
heart goes one way and your head goes
another
um in principle I I I actually do
support this but what the officers say
is is 100 right it doesn't meet any of
the conditions for building the green
belt
um the sad thing is if they've actually
put the processing plan there which
would have had larger cultural need we
won't be having this discussion
um
yeah I mean
personally I would love to support it
and say yeah but I don't it's the case
if we don't follow the policies and I
mean looking at the neighborhood plan
which has been referred to several times
and no it's not enforced yet
first thing ensure that any new
development in the parish whether it is
new housing conversion or existing
buildings or other development requires
no intrusion to the existing green vowel
um this is this is the problem you and
often the problem with with Naval plans
because they put things in black and
white then you have something that they
don't want to make an exception of
um so yeah we've got a lot of support
from the village saying they want it but
we're also realistically having the
village saying at the same time saying
they don't want this to happen and if we
approve it and then we go with permanent
in 20 years time like will be a house
there that thing's being given so we
just don't know that so it's a hard one
I loved support it but based on based on
what we've got it doesn't need any of
the criteria at all for building the
greenhouse
um
I'm in agreement with David on that it
is one of those
um
that your heart goes with the uh support
in it but unfortunately we've got to
look at the framework that we that we're
constrained by both nationally and
locally
um and I think it makes it a very
difficult decision
um but I've on that grounds I don't
think it mitigates
enough uh the intrusion into the green
belt
Saudi speakers I can't participate
further after they've spoken and
answered questions
right if we've got uh no more
contributors to the debate
um I've been heard everything today and
the official recommendation before us uh
what is the view of the committee on the
application I am now opening the floor
to motions
thank you
yeah you can you know I would like to
move officer's recommendations please
I'll second that
thank you
uh right the uh
on the floor we've got to accept uh
officer recommendations uh so we're now
going to take that to a roll call
thank you chair
councilor Cooper
counselor forces
for
councilor girl
four
councilor Hancock
for
councilor Hartzell for
councilor Jones for
counselor Lacy for
counselor
and councilor Rouse
four
that's unanimous share the motion has
passed uh thank you
um that's the Liberto if you can leave
the chamber please and keep thank you
for your attendance and thank you for
all your comments
okay
okay thank you David
thank you
all right if everyone's happy I'll move
straight on to the next application
um so this is uh application Ned 22
stroke zero one zero four two stroke a d
Wing width
foreign
[Music]
members unless you have any points of
order that you feel cannot wait
uh could you please reserve these or any
questions about the process until the
end so I'm now going to move you out to
where Graham Cooper was doing the last
presentation thank you
thanks chair we just firing up the
presentation now so just borrow me a
second thank you Alice
all right then so this is an application
for advertisement consent for the
installation of four signs on the parish
rooms at wingworth two signs will be
vertically installed and the other two
positioned horizontally
following concerns raised by the case
officer and neighboring residents the
original submitted scheme has been
amended to remove any internal
illumination from the proposed signage
at one single late representation was
reported yesterday that was just
offering some officer commentary around
the scale of the proposed signage
there's been no third-party comments and
there are no technical reasons why this
application should be refused
are the main issues as laid out in the
officer reports are the impacts on the
proposed advertisements on the character
and appearance of the site and the
surrounding Street Scene the impact on
public immunity and Highway Safety
QRS so this slide this illustrates the
application site shaded in Orange the
application site sits within the
settlement development limit for
wingoweth
with open Countryside to the west of the
western New Road
you've got detached Residential
Properties to the north east and south
of the application site
we've also got an established equestrian
development opposite the site along with
a recently constructed holiday Cottage
where they're set at a lower level than
the Hedge line which is on New Road the
land levels to the West Fall Away down
into the valley
so this is the location plan which has
been submitted with the application
you can see the site edged in red
hopefully there
the plan illustrates more clearly the
relationship between the site and the
neighboring properties you can see the
existing car park associated with the
parish rooms
just off on a limb to the right hand
side there
and how close it is to the existing
properties which surround it next slide
please
so this plan illustrates the position of
the proposed signage we've got two
vertical signs are proposed at points
six and eight on this plan
this is to the front and rear entrance
points of the building two horizontal
signs will be positioned at points one
and five on the plan and these being at
the side of the main entrance on New
Road and one on the North Gable
perfect
so this plan this illustrates the design
of the proposed vertical and horizontal
signage
just to be clear the dimensions
Illustrated on this plan are for
Illustrated purposes only and this is
just to show the difference between the
horizontal and vertical design of the
signage
next slide please
so this plan is a more detailed plan and
it illustrates the exact dimensions and
design of the signage
the lettering will be 1.85 meters in
width and 0.4 of a meters height
vertical design is just a 90 degree
rotated version of what you can see here
So the plan shows that the signage will
be constructed with internal lighting
but just to be clear the units will not
be switched on
this plan also confirms the final
Dimensions as we've discussed
the applicant has confirmed that they
will in the future explore Illuminating
the signage but this will be in
consultation with officers and Neighbors
and I have advised that a new permission
will be required to illuminate the
signage
and just just to make sure that that's
clear of included a condition ensuring
that the signs will not be illuminated
in any way included in the officer
recommendation
and the next few slides are just a
couple of photos taken from site that
members will have seen yesterday at the
virtual site visit this is taken from
New Road facing the north elevation of
the parish rooms and a horizontal sign
will be included in the elevation that
you can see there
this next slide is taken from the car
park to the rear of the parish rooms
and a vertical
sign will be included on the elevation
next to the rear entrance just to offer
a bit of a way marking into the building
and the final slide
this is taken from New Road and a
vertical sign will be installed to the
left of the door enter install we can
just about make out there
and a horizontal sign will be on the the
blank Gable that you can see between the
doors and the small window it just helps
you know way Mark people into the
building and that concludes the
presentation
uh thank you
um
as well no speakers on this application
we will go straight to questions to what
the officers again I would like to keep
this part of the proceedings focused on
getting clarity about any point you are
not sure of so I would be grateful if
you could not move any motions at this
stage
do you have any questions for officers
okay
yes I would like to ask the officer are
these actually going to be hardwired
sort of may possibly be accidentally
switched on
uh or left
remote of any power supply
so I'm advised that they will connect
the signage up but they won't be
switched on so
you know we could include a note maybe
just to make it clear uh you know the
condition is there and it's enforceable
so if the lighted lighting is put on by
accident then
you know and I think that
if it is accidentally put on that might
be an interesting test to see what that
harm is because I know the parish rooms
are looking at some form of an
illumination for this signage but they
want to work in conjunction with us and
the residents because there has been
concerns about all the lighting on the
site but you know we have got a
condition saying that it won't be
illuminated
and that's that's all we can kind of
secure for you today
yeah I would like to think that it
couldn't possibly be turned on if they
come back and obviously
that's a different yeah different
question
any other questions for officers nope
uh okay thanks please uh I've been heard
everything today and those are
recommendations before us uh what is the
view of the community on this
application I am now opening the floor
uh to motions
oh well to debate sorry
counselor Cooper
um I'm a bit with Tony on this one I
think I think we need to make sure that
his it can't be turned on I think we
need some condition in there just to say
and and then let him bring it back and
whether we can stipulate something later
on that they can have so many lit up or
rather than I think eight sounds all lit
up on one building's a bit excessive to
be honest
um
yeah
no it's not like the building doesn't
stand out anyway is it
uh rant members
um do we have a motion put forward for
this application
right but yeah going with that I'll
second that
we need to do a roll call can we just go
to a show ends
we'll go for sure once yep
just with the condition uh where am I
possible yes
okay
uh right that brings us to the end of
all the decisions we want to make now
called the planning officers to explain
our next report automate appeals lodged
and determined
I could share this is a good raft of
appeal decisions that
um reporting this month and I'm taking
it all members are receiving the the
appeal decision so so that's a good
thing there are a few here chair would
just like to make reference to the first
is the first sorry chair do we want to
invite counselor Hancock back in he
probably doesn't know where finished oh
sorry you're not entirely sure he's
still here but we'll just go out and
just check he's left his pen
foreign
first of all chair the the first appeal
lodged at paragraph 1.2 which is
and site that many members may be aware
of but it's the the West Hamley Ministry
so there's a enforced notes been served
on the activities there and that will be
heard in due course the the second
reference I do want to
um bring members attention to chair is
it's paragraphs 1.5 the four appeals
there they're all enforcement appeals
but they do go into some detail the
discussion that we've had this afternoon
regarding Greenbelt and
how the decisions of the inspectors have
been reached in all of those four cases
that who make interesting reading chair
and particularly the um the appeal
decision at cart ref also discusses
issues around impact on the conservation
area at
home's field but it does have other
applications elsewhere in the district
and also regarding the fallback position
which you'll often be faced with so I
would if you haven't already I would
encourage you to have a look at all four
of those and read through for the new
race some very useful learning points in
terms of decision making
happy to take any questions share but
that they were just the points I was
going to raise thank you for that Adrian
any questions
nope all right thank you
uh thank you members do we agree to note
the report
just show ones yep okay uh I have no
urgent business so I'll now declare the
meeting closed thank you for your
attendance